what's up everyone
lunch money time while while she's
trying to get rich so that's just trying
to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
planet evilova marinova
bang bang don't think i forgot while
while she's trying to get rid of us
trying to get our lunch money right
block five is sponsoring lunch money
they're awesome we're awesome you'll be
awesome if you go get an account
go earn up to 8.6 apy in an interest
bearing account
with block by blockbuy.com or you can
buy
bitcoin on there crypto exchange
duh if you ain't got no bitcoin go get
some everybody needs a little bit of
bitcoin
what go get some yeah go get some duh i
mean it's easy you just go on the
exchange and you just hit buy and then
you buy
come on it's great uh blackfy.com pomp
go check it out all right what's up
namaste
namaste oh yeah that's right okay i'm on
day three
of living alone kind of my brothers are
here buddy how's it going
uh it's good we're still surviving we've
been uh
you know chilling yeah you guys i leave
and he starts cooking
okay ah you know we did some cooking
yeah
okay ready yeah jp morgan chase
said its digital currency jpm coin is
being used commercially for the first
time this week by a large technology
client
to send payments around the world that
development along with other behind the
scenes moves
persuaded jp morgan to create a new
business to houses blockchain and
digital currency efforts called
onyx uh said the bank's global head of
wholesale payments the unit has more
than a hundred
dedicated staffers do we remember when
jamie dimon called it all a scam
yeah we remember look i'm cool with jp
morgan getting on the bitcoin train
i'm cool with that and the reason why
i'm cool with it is because everyone
eventually gonna get on the bitcoin
train
and i have no clue what jamie dimon's
personal views on bitcoin are at the
moment
but the fact that we went from the ceo
saying i'm gonna fire anyone for trading
this stuff for being stupid
and saying it was a fraud to now they've
got analysts putting out messages uh
notes
that say that it could double or triple
in price yeah okay that's a change of
tune
smart people when they're presented with
new information they change their mind
i'm cool with all that what i'm not cool
with
is the fact that jp morgan
somehow gets a pass from regulators
they're creating a stable coin that is
backed by
fiat currency but when facebook tried to
do this
everyone freaked out what did they say
don't be the first one
the door yeah but still my point being
i'm more worried about jp morgan's
stablecoin than i am about the
facebook libra and it's because or go
ahead but i think we all knew
that what facebook did it would have
it would open doors for everybody else
regardless if they got burned in the
process
yeah and i think jp morgan had
previously said that they were gonna do
this
but there wasn't any real movement on it
but the crazy part is
it's the corporate uh what i call the
corporate central bank
playbook i think is what i called it and
all that is
is that these banks are building central
banks
the central banks don't realize that and
the regulators don't realize that yet
but here's what they're going to do
they're going to launch a digital coin
and say it's backed by the dollar
they're going to get
widespread adoption with their customers
with retail users all this stuff
and at some point in the future jp
morgan will unpeg
that digital coin from the
dollar and now all of a sudden jp morgan
will be in control of how much they
print of it it won't be tied to the us
dollar anymore so i think
anthony said this one's at a panel and
then there was a lot of like
people didn't like that because it was
that kind of
audience people don't like when i say
the truth
i was right about bitcoin i'm gonna be
right about that too
it's fine i'm not right all the time i'm
actually wrong a lot of the time maybe
sometimes
then i'm right i'm not but okay flynn
reminds me every time i'm wrong
next robin hood co-ceo
and co-founder vlad tenef told cnbc
that young customers of the company view
volatility and market downturns as
buying opportunities for the long term
amid the pandemic robin hood saw
deposits into accounts that were equal
to
or multiples of the stimulus checks from
the trump's administration the trump
administration's 2.2 trillion cares act
10f told cnbc what yeah people
well if you give young people money what
do they do they put it they either
gamble
or they put it into uh the market and on
top of that they weren't able to go
anywhere that's the other thing if you
gave it them money in a normal time
where they weren't in quarantine maybe
they would have went to the movies or
they would have went and spent it and
you know going out with friends or
drinking or whatever
but they couldn't go anywhere they
literally were locked in their houses
so it's like cool i got extra money my
bank account might as well do something
with it and sports wasn't on
so makes sense to me is this good for
the market that kind of inexperienced
and juvenile investors are participating
in such great
volumes there's no
difference between a 20 year old kid
who's trading for the first time and a
professional investor
because nobody had lived through a
global pandemic before
and on top of that on top of that
what the data is showing is that the
people who made the most money so far
were the younger people who dialed into
good even though they're called the dumb
money yeah
they're so dumb that they made more
money than the professional investors
right
now again could it be just randomness
sure could it be some other sort of um
you know market force at play of course
right there handed money all that kind
of stuff
but if you remember the people who sold
at the bottom of the market in march
tended to be older people
right who have a lot of experience
because of liquidity concerns and they
didn't want to then have their wealth
kind of
uh devalued away or i'm sorry lose value
in their wealth so they sold and the
market recovered
and they don't get any of that upside so
really it's older people who are closer
to retirement or
in retirement they got shaken out of
their position young people capitalized
on it
and that's where we are today got it
ready yes millions of jobless americans
are poised to lose their unemployment
benefits at the end of the year without
action from congress to extend temporary
aid programs
a federal program paying benefits to gig
workers and others such as the
self-employed
freelancers contractors and part-timers
is poised to lapse
after december in all there are about
13.5 million people in those two
programs
more than half of the roughly 23 million
people receiving unemployment benefits
according to labor department data so
people are saying that there's going to
be an enormous cliff at the end of the
year
this is really sad the two things that i
really really
really uh feel bad about is one
the lack of support for small businesses
in america right now
i think there's getting decimated and
then on top of that
uh the lack of support for the average
citizen
right and you know when you look at it
from a sense of
uh do i think that the government should
be
uh just you know funding the lifestyle
of people no but i don't think that's
what's happening i think that there's
a situation where the government can uh
prevent people from
uh going hungry and doing things like
that so social programs that can work
um when done correctly and then it's
give them the knowledge
and information they need to go and
start businesses get a job you know
retraining like all that kind of stuff
and so
it's kind of a sequential thing you've
got to be able to one stop the bleeding
and then two
um you know put people in a good
position the sad part is i don't think
that there's a lot of conversation about
the average person going on inside of
the uh political
uh debate right now i think everyone's
just trying to figure out won the
election
and then two is uh how do they keep
bailing out wall street how do they keep
bailing out corporations yeah this is
the uh the layoffs
that were once thought to be temporary
have now become permanent
many of them and jobless durations are
rising
so that's not great not not not uh not a
good situation
okay ready i'm ready i like how you say
ready every time like we're about to
take off on a race go ahead
on monday the college board released its
annual trends in college pricing and
student aid report
which indicates that this year 2020
college costs
increased at the lowest rate in decades
that means that covet is kind of
freezing college
costs for now why is that the costs
never go down
because inflation no
oh it's because they just like
explain to me how uh you change their
product but the price doesn't go down
you literally are giving an inferior
product to people but somehow the price
didn't go down
oh you mean this year yeah what why are
people paying the same like even flat
prices
why didn't the price go down because the
colleges have to survive
but you're not given the same you don't
have the same cost structure
i mean tuition has historically risen
roughly three percent each year but over
the past several months many schools
have made public commitments to freeze
tuition
it's because they've built this like
regulatory capture type environment
where it's
only people with this certain
certification can provide
the college degree so rather than people
try to break that down now what you're
just seeing is employers say you don't
need a college degree
like we want you to be trained on the
job but like google they have programs
where
hey you're gonna be a product manager at
google cool take our course
and we'll teach you everything you need
to know and then you can and then you
can come work here
like that's a great uh initiative
compared to
hey go take on you know 100 000 worth of
uh student loan debt so that you can
then get a piece of paper and try to get
a job
why don't you just go to companies hey i
know i want to work at google google
just training to be a product manager
and then you can go yeah but nobody or
very few people know exactly where they
want to work when they're in college or
before college
yeah but eventually what will happen is
if you get the google product manager
certification then that'll be accepted
by other tech companies
right unless facebook and facebook
doesn't like it
nah no they would love it because they
know that you are uh
that you are getting uh trained
correctly
all right ready yes yeah i did it again
okay um spacex is expanding the beta
test of its starlink satel
starlink satellite internet service uh
reaching out via email on monday to
people who expressed interest in signing
up for the service
known as the better than nothing beta
test
according to multiple screenshots of the
email initial starlink service
is priced at 99 a month plus a 499
499 upfront cost to order the starlink
kit
that kit includes a user terminal to
connect to the satellites
a mounting tripod and a wi-fi router
that's kind of cool
can we get one for what our wi-fi is
fast
yeah but like i just want one why
i just want one i'll point it right out
the window you want to connect to a
satellite
yeah like just have my own little
satellite that i could control tell it
come closer
okay now go away is that a yes
you're so funny i'll just get one while
you're gone and i'll install it and when
you come back then you can make a
decision
people were laughing yesterday at you
saying you'd punch the murder hornet
in the air yeah
look at that a murder horner don't stand
a chance you ever seen somebody punch a
hornet
no you're about to and have you ever
seen somebody order
a satellite wi-fi system while their
wife was gone no but you about to
okay next all right ready
um so burger king popeyes and tim
hortons are getting
new drive-throughs to boost sales in the
coronavirus age
restaurant brands international which
owns these brands said that
it is planning to modernize the
drive-through experience at over
ten thousand restaurants by middle by
the middle of
2022 that includes installation of uh
over forty thousand digital menu screens
uh or
four per drive through lane the screens
offer contactless payment methods to
speed up cars progression to the
director et cetera et cetera
why do you think these people this is
like a pretty permanent
change are they betting that like
kovid's nowhere
close to being over yeah i think that
just like the world's gonna change
pretty significantly
and also i think that this gave them an
opportunity to rethink
like how they uh structure a lot of
stuff right like
it wouldn't surprise me if in some of
these cases that yeah there's some
upfront cost to how you gotta build it
and that type of stuff but
what happens if actually this leads to a
cost reduction over time it makes you
more efficient it's a
it's a better use of your space like
it's just all that kind of stuff
uh can go into play and then also just
consumer behavior is changing
like consumers just are not going to do
certain things that they previously did
like i know for me
if i uh and walking in somewhere i never
thought about like oh i'm touching the
door handle that somebody else has
touched
that just wasn't a thought in my mind
i'm not germaphobe i don't care i'll
like lick the door
yeah i'd like lick the door not really
lick it but like basically that was my
attitude
but now i touch it and then i like walk
around with my hand like this
until i get somewhere where i can wash
it right like
you know it's just it
go ahead what do you think oh what do i
think about that
i'm all about not touching stuff um
remember when we were in bulgaria and
like they had the credit card where you
just tap it you don't have to swipe it
you don't have to insert it whatever
contactless i believe yeah so the fact
that we don't have that in america
i mean it's you know we do have that
do we yeah i think we like you and i
just don't have the card but i think
that are you behind the times
what i i'm cool i just use cash
like hard cash straight money cash yes
credit card it's like it's like
scratched and messed up why would you
need to get a new one if it's not
expired
i'm not doing it for the fancy looks
look at me i got a nike shirt on where
the logo was off
all right nice you look pretty good
premium logo
um okay i know you all heard me say she
looked pretty and she ignored me go
ahead
oh i didn't hear that oh thank you oh
yeah selective hearing go ahead
no i would have selected to hear that um
so this joke comes from a lunch money
viewer
why isn't her name i don't know because
i took a screenshot
without their name but i remember it was
something inappropriate so i'm not gonna
oh okay it's always the inappropriate
unions that provide the good jokes go
ahead
why did the banana go to the doctor
it wasn't peeling well
i see a smile i see it i see a it's
trying to come out
no i actually was just thinking about i
might make myself a little banana split
but
other than that no problem what you know
about banana splits
nothing i literally don't know what that
is i i actually
not a banana split because i think that
has ice cream in it and it's 10 o'clock
in the morning
i think i'm gonna make uh uh a parfait
that's right
i don't know how to make them but i'm
gonna figure it out it's not that hard
yeah john my brother and i we we've been
uh
we've been surviving you know it's fine
yesterday i think that we ate some
tostitos hint of lime chips
by the end of the week i just picture
you looking like um
what's his name uh in in india
passed away yes i knew what you were
talking about i will not look like that
all right don't worry we're safe and
sound we're alive
our hearts are beating we can smell
everything so we don't
have covid we're good to go we've been
very very safe
and uh i made
my bed today and john made the bed on
the couch so like
amazing amazing great to hear great
don't worry everyone
we're surviving i might even be able to
do this forever without pelina
that's it for lunch monday today see you
guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends